好,大家好,我是馬克洋
今天,好,謝謝大家
今天我會用數學的方式帶大家看看
人類在面對金錢跟風險的時候都會犯一樣的錯誤
而且這些錯誤是可以被數學預測的
這些錯誤不是因為人類不聰明
而是因為人類的大腦是設計用來在大自然中快速的生存
而不是用來做這些理性跟抽象的決策
就是很多人會以為說
人類是千奇百怪,百百種
所以大家會犯的錯誤
會很不一樣
有的人多一點,有的人少一點
但事實上呢
幾乎所有的人的大腦結果都是幾乎完全一樣的
也就是說大家都會犯
幾乎一樣的錯誤
而且這些錯誤呢
是能夠被行為經濟學預測
然後更重要的是呢
行為經濟學給出了很多具體的解決方法
那我們今天就是要來看
就是
我們用數學的方式怎麼樣子
分析這些在交易當中
大家都必定會發生的錯誤
有一群交易者他們是
常常贏錢
他們是高勝率的玩家
但是他們卻是長期的輸家
就是大家可能
都有經驗
一次突然蒙受了一個很大的虧損
一次突然爆掉這樣的情況
那如果呢
今天這場演講可以讓大家
生涯當中少爆掉一次
那
就是你少數一次好幾十萬
那其實就等於是你多賺好幾十萬
那
這個價值就是非常非常高的
好然後
或許有些人還是不認識我
簡單的自我介紹一下
我以前是一個醫生
然後
我以前都是
數理班的
然後後來在
讀陽明醫學系
然後在高中的時候
我拿過一次
科學奧林匹拉的
金牌跟
世界冠軍
那就是一個
每個國家派出幾個
那個國家最會考試的
小朋友
然後這些高中生
互相比賽
誰是
這個地球上最會科學的人
這樣的一個遊戲
然後
後來我也
在當醫生的最後幾年有開過
遊戲的直播
然後
就是那時候
就叫做
馬克陽
然後
當時也連續三個月都
在爐石戰績打到
亞洲伺服器的
第一名
然後後來呢
我也有經營補習班
就是
然後後來
我在兩年前
也投資了一家
四人企業
然後在那個金模槍公司
我買到變成
那個公司最大的股東
然後
就是投給自己
然後自己當代理董事長
經營了那個公司一段時間
那現在那個公司已經
非常穩定也非常好
當然大家如果
有想要買金模槍
這個舒緩肩頸痠痛的話
也可以
上網買金模槍
好然後
我在29歲左右的時候
就開始退休
然後
我就沒有繼續當醫生
然後環遊世界
去世界各地玩
那去年
我有超過一半的時間
都不在台灣
在
當然有一些是純粹旅遊的
去日本啊
接國家玩
然後
也有
去年啊
有四個月
我是在拉斯維加斯
就是
在那邊
住在賭場裡面
然後
用
這些
數學遊戲來賺錢
然後當然我
從2022年左右吧
就到現在
就一直有跟
群益
期貨合作
來辦演講
然後
每年大概會
辦一到兩次的演講吧
好
然後
我去年
有四個月都住在拉斯維加斯
玩21點算牌
就是
我不當醫生之後
我盡量
每年都學習
一到兩件新的事情
或許更多
可能三四件新的事情
然後去年另外一件我學的事情
是玩一個叫做
Shadowverse的
卡牌遊戲
然後也是有打到
伺服器的第一名
不過呢
因為那個
完全不能賺錢
所以大家可能
興趣就不是很高
我們就還是來講
跟金錢遊戲有關的
就是
21點
大家不知道有沒有看到
一部電影叫
決勝21點
就是
算牌
然後
被賭場封殺的
這樣一個故事
那我就
自己自學上網查一些資料
事實上
21點
是如何打敗賭場的
這個是
60年前
數學家在
計算機剛開始的時候
就已經發展出來
數學策略
所以這些數學策略
其實是
網路上就很容易可以找到的
當然
要
用21點
打敗賭場
並不是
純粹
有那些數學策略就可以了
就是
還要有很多
具體執行的步驟嘛
就是並不是
你上網查了一個表格
然後你就有辦法
打敗賭場
那我也有製作了一套
完整的
體系
然後來教怎麼樣子
算牌打敗賭場
然後我最近也寫了一本
一百多頁的書
但是不會出版
就是
完整的記錄了我
這個
在拉斯維加斯
是怎麼樣
擊敗這些賭場
然後這些方式
具體是怎麼做
那
就是
我看起來
玩過很多不同的遊戲
然後做過很多不同的事情
但是其實他們都是
同一套思想體系
在不同場景的運用
就是
主要就是數學
然後遊戲策略
然後行為經濟學
就是接下來我們今天會
看到的很多內容
然後還有
資金的風險管理
還有情緒管理制度
這些都是
有規則的各式各樣的遊戲裡面
我會
首先先建立一套完整的體系
然後接下來就是執行它
所以
其實呢
最困難的是
如何建立一套制度
然後
這套制度
不僅是包含數學策略
也包含了
你要怎麼控制自己的情緒
怎麼讓
你確保你自己是可以有紀律的執行
這也是非常重要的
就是
今天這場演講講的內容應該會是
其他的投資演講都幾乎完全沒有聽過的
因為
大部分的投資演講
或說大部分的交易者
他們都沒有系統性的深入學過行為經濟學
所以
大部分他們對於
人性必定會犯的錯誤
他們的解決方式都是說
我們要控制自己的心態
控制自己的心魔
然後不要貪心
但實際上
這個並不能夠解決問題
因為
人的大腦的結構設計就是這樣
我們就是一樣會犯一樣的錯誤
這就像是
就是有一個人要去考試的時候
然後你跟他說
不要粗心
盡量每題都要寫對
就是這樣的提醒
並沒有辦法
幫助他不要粗心
或者是每題都寫對
那
實際上行為經濟學
已經對人的大腦有越來越多的研究
所以我們也越來越知道要怎麼樣子
用制度來避免這一套錯誤
好
那
行為經濟學跟傳統經濟學很不一樣的地方
就是在於
傳統經濟學是
假設人類會非常理性地做出很完美的決策
但是實際上
人類並沒有辦法做出完美的決策
因為人的大腦就並不是用來設計做這件事情的
那
行為經濟學用
很多的
具體的實驗和很多的數學分析
來得出了
人為什麼會在
一樣的情況下都犯一樣的錯誤
好
然後
為什麼
我們會講
為什麼在股市當中
我們要
依循數學
而不能依循人類的直覺
也就是說
不能夠依循盤感來交易
因為如果依循盤感來交易的話
事實上你在第一次下單之前
你的長期結果就已經註定了
我們都會做出
在
自然而然做出
跟
市場應該要做
數學上
正確的事情
完全相反的事情
好
那
這是一個有趣的問題
就是
我們做投資是為了賺錢
還是為了快樂
我們這個
還是互動一下好了
覺得投資是為了賺錢的舉手
大概
略超過一半的人
那覺得
投資是為了快樂的舉手
當然這個純粹是一個
哲學的問題
跟這個數學對錯完全沒有關係
因為
事實上
我們人類做所有事情
都是為了快樂
就是就算你是為了
實現非常崇高的理想
事實上本質上
還是為了快樂
所以就是
它就是一個
純粹哲學上的問題
但是呢
接下來我們會
多次提到這個問題
然後
就是因為人類實際上
做所有事情
都是為了
Utility
就是為了快樂
那當然我們賺很多錢
也是為了
最後把這些錢
轉換為快樂
但是我們在投資的過程當中
當中
我們有可能會
暗暗的
就直接
直接做出了
當下會最舒服
最快樂的決定
那這些決定
有可能會讓你當下更快樂
而且這些快樂是可以被預期的
但是呢
就是這些決定
會是數學上
錯誤的決定
好
首先我們先講一個
這個
非常常見的策略
就是
加碼攤平
或是叫做
瓦丁格爾
背頭法
那
這個策略呢
他是一個勝率很容易超過99%
甚至是更高的策略
那他的策略核心就是說
你去賭場
然後
玩一個
接近5050的遊戲
那如果你輸一塊錢
下一把就再下兩塊
然後再輸就再下四塊
再輸再下八塊
那直到你最後有贏一手的時候
你就會贏一塊錢
那當然也不一定要是一塊錢嘛
你可以是
一千塊或是一萬塊
然後
如果你長期的不停的重複這件事情的話
那你在99%以上的時間
都會是贏錢的
甚至有很多人他們
到現在都還實際執行這件事情
他們可能就覺得說
我不貪心啊
我就
每天去賭場
用這個方式
贏五次一千塊
一天贏個五千塊
但是呢
這個是一個
勝率非常高的
負期望值策略
也就是說賭場會非常歡迎
也非常喜歡賭客
去賭場做這件事情
因為
這些賭客他們的遊戲體驗會很好
他們大部分的時候會賺錢
但是呢
他們會在一次
突然爆輸
輸光他們全部的錢
那這個
背頭髮
就算沒有聽過
馬丁格爾這個詞的人
很多的人都會自然而然的
想出這樣的策略
或者是他們也不一定想出來
他們就
很容易自然而然的
想要做這件事情
那就是
這個也是有
非常嚴謹的數學原因跟根據
如果使用這種
凹單攤平的策略的話
他們就會在大部分的時候
贏錢
然後會再一次
突然爆掉全部輸光
這個是告訴我們說
就是
我們做一個策略
其實很多人都會問說
那這樣的話
這個策略的勝率是多少
但是其實
這個策略勝率是多少
只跟這個策略執行起來的快樂有趣程度有關
那
並不代表這個策略
賺不賺錢
那這一個策略
要能夠賺錢
最基本的是
他要是正期望值
那當然還要有很多其他的
因素來
衡量一個策略
是不是能夠
應該被穩定執行
而不只是正期望值
好
然後
一樣講一個
就是
聽起來很像是廢話
但是
卻
很難被做到
就是
我們應該更長的
持有賺錢的倉位
還有更短的
持有虧錢的倉位
也就是說
如果一個東西
他是在賺錢的
那
你
更
不應該把它賣掉
然後如果一個東西在虧錢
你更應該要把它
就是
處分平常賣掉
那這是因為
以趨勢來說
通常
平均來說
比較強的
資產
更容易繼續更強
那如果
比較弱的資產
比較更容易
繼續更弱
畢竟這個就是趨勢
那但是呢
實際上
人類會做的事情是
幾乎完全相反的
也就是說
大部分人他們是
賺錢心裡就很慌
那
反而是賠錢的時候
他們才可以安心的
持有他們的資產
那就是他們會賣掉
賺錢的部位
然後留下
虧損的部位
如果
他買了一個股票
然後那個股票
一直在下跌的話
那他們就會覺得
自己在長期投資
然後他們就可以很安心的
長期的持有
他們
正在虧錢的資產
那那個資產
可能公司
開始有一些利好
或者是說
時代改變了
比如說他是
一個長期
虧錢的AI公司
然後結果
突然AI發展很好
他開始賺錢了
然後漲到自己的成本價
他就解套了
然後他就
把這個
開始賺錢的東西賣掉
這個是非常正常
非常常見的事情
那
這邊都還是
這個
跟數學沒什麼關係的描述
讓接下來我們都會用很多數學方式來
講解為什麼這些事情
必然會發生
就是數學能夠預測人心
而且不同的人都會犯一樣的錯誤
那當然
這邊還是要付諸一下
就是
現代人類的
心理學的
這些研究
幾乎都是
研究一個叫做
Wired的群體
也就是說
西方的
白人
然後
在民主化
然後有受教育的
這些人
那當然
就是在股票市場裡
也大部分是
這些人嘛
所以
就是
我們付諸一下
就是說我們人類的研究
大部分是研究
這些
有受教育的
的
民主化世界的人
那
當然這也是非常符合
我們股市的場景
好
那
在我們進行
更深入更困難的
數學分析之前
我們都還是要講一點點的
前置的知識
第一個是
DNU就是
編輯效應遞減
Diminishing Marginal Utility
那
Utility呢
通常它被翻譯為效用
但是我也喜歡把它翻譯為
快樂或者是爽度
那
這個
遞效用是會遞減的
也就是說
你賺的第100萬
跟你賺了第100個100萬
他能夠帶給你的快樂是差距非常大的
如果你是一個大學生
然後
你的
總存款是不到10萬的
那如果
你突然
彩票中獎了
中了一個100萬
你是
絕對是
快樂到不行
歡天喜地
但是如果你是郭台銘
你已經
有非常非常多的錢了
結果你的發票中了100萬
然後那個助理跑來跟你說
郭董
你發票中了100萬
他說
不要告訴我這種小事
浪費我的時間
好不好
我根本懶得花時間
知道我中了100萬這種小事
就是因為
編輯效應遞減嘛
你
前面
吃了第1個壽司
覺得很好吃
吃到第100個壽司的時候
可能就已經沒那麼好吃了
好
那就是
所以
因為
邊際效應遞減
那如果
這個
x 軸是
你的財富
y 軸是
你可以
得到的快樂的話
那可以看到
它是一個
凹口向下的圖形
那當然我畫的是
這個比較誇張
比較彎的這個情況
那實際上
邊際效應遞減
是很慢的
就是
它應該沒有到這麼晚
不過這樣的話
大家比較容易理解
就是
你在賺的第1個100萬
跟賺的第2個100萬
跟賺的第3個100萬
到
可能賺第10個100萬
其實你獲得快樂
是差不多的
然後呢
再講一個
前置的知識
是一個不等事
那
反正我只是
就是
記錄一下
它的數學形式
讓
這個
看YouTube影片的觀眾
也都可以
很容易的
就是知道在講什麼
好
那簡單來說呢
就是如果它是一個
凹口向上的圖形的話
那
在
中間
這個函數
平均值的位置
會比
它的
旁邊
幾個位置
的函數值的平均
還更下面
簡單來說就是
左邊跟右邊的
這兩個點
它們的
平均也就是
那個橘橘的線的中心點
會比下面那個點更上面
這應該是在圖形上很直觀可以理解的事情
好那確實這個高中我們是幾乎沒有學習過不等事
但是
我們大致上應該可以用直性的來理解就是說
如果它的圖形
是凹口向上的
的話
那你在
中間
就是下面的這個點
它會比你在上面隨便取兩個點
然後連在一起的
中心點
位置更下面
對吧
好
然後這個是價值函數
價值函數說的就是
下面一樣
x軸是你的
損益
如果在
中間的
右邊
這邊的話
就是你正在賺錢的時候
然後左邊就是
你越虧越多錢的時候
那
再往上的話
就是說
你精神上得到越來越多的快樂
然後越往下就是精神上
這個越來越痛苦
那這當然是
這個
至少它的方向是很容易理解的嘛
你在賺越來越多錢的時候就越來越快樂
而且這個快樂是會稍微邊際效益遞減的
你後面賺到了越來越多錢
多帶給你的快樂是稍微越來越小的
所以在
這個
右上角這邊
它會是一個凹口向下的圖形
那在第三向線的話
它是一個凹口向上的圖形
也就是說
你越虧越多錢
越虧越多錢
那
虧更多錢帶給你
新增的痛苦是
越來越少越來越少
所以在第三向線
它會是一個凹口向上的圖形
好
那我們剛剛也學過了
這個
Jensen's Inequality
就是
詹森不等式
那我們就看第三向線這個部分好了
如果
你在
虧損當中的某一個點
然後這時候如果你停損的話
那就等於是
你的不快樂的位置就固定在了
這個中間
例如說下面這個點的位置
但是呢
如果你
選擇不停損凹單的話
那你可能有
幾乎一樣的機率
是會
往左移到左邊這個點
或者是有大概一半的機率
會往右移到右邊的這個點
但是呢
無論如何
這兩個點
它們的平均
都會在
你直接停損
也就是下面這個點
之上
那我們
就是
在這個圖表裡面
越上面是
心理上越快樂嘛
也就是說
無論你是在哪一個位置
例如說
如果你
現在是在
這個位置
那你的不快樂程度
在這個位置
那如果你不停損的話
你有大約一半的機率
例如說
上升到
這個位置
那有一半的機會
是下降到這個位置
但是
無論如何
左右的兩個點
它們的平均
都會在你現在
確定停損的之上
也就是說
停損跟不停損
這兩個決定
相比起來
不停損
平均來說
是會比較快樂的
那當然這兩個點
不一定是要
是
離這麼遠啦
就是
在局部附近的話
也都是完全
有一樣的結論
就是
只要在整個第三向線
它都是一個
凹口向上的形式的話
那
無論你目前
虧損多少
如果你決定不停損
平均來說
相對於停損
都是比較快樂的
好
這個也是
行為經濟學當中
其中一個最基礎
最重要的
展望理論
也就是說
我們可以看到
第一向線跟第三向線
第三向線它是
更往下的
也就是說
人對
相同金額的
快樂跟痛苦
他們的感受
是不一樣的
譬如說
你今天如果
賺了一萬塊
那你會獲得一點點快樂
但如果你今天
虧損了一萬塊
虧損一萬塊的痛苦的感受
是超過賺一萬塊的快樂的
那大概會是在
可能1.3倍或到2倍之間
這個範圍
好
那所以展望理論的
兩個主要點
第一個就是
人對
損失的痛苦
會大於
對同等
獲利的快樂
然後再來就是
在獲利的時候
人會更保守
然後在
虧損的時候
更容易冒險
那這張圖跟這張圖是一樣的
不過
就是
我們
在
用這個看起來更彎的圖
再解釋一次
為什麼人類會更傾向於提早停利
然後不停損
例如說我們設定了一個策略
那一個好的策略
大部分他的停利是會比停損更長的
如果我們設定
在賺200塊的時候要停利
然後
虧100塊的時候要停損
但是呢
我們現在在
賺100塊的時候
那我們的快樂是在那個100上面的那個點
那
如果現在有大約一半的機會
我們是
會變成賺200塊
然後另外一半的情況是會
跌回去變成零
那對於人類來說
賺
變成賺200塊跟
變回去變成零沒有賺
平均來說
你的快樂是比直接停利更少的
也就是說
就是大部分人會說的是
落袋為安嘛
我們不貪心嘛
就是
那雖然我們設定要賺200
但是沒關係
賺100就好了
因為這樣至少確定我今天是賺錢的
那感覺
他平均的快樂是比較高的
所以
雖然你設定的是
要賺200
但是
就是200停利
但是你在賺100的時候
人性就會讓你更想要提早停利
那在虧損的時候
例如說現在是
虧100
那或者是我們
放大一點
如果現在是虧1萬塊
那
對大部分人來說
如果現在不停損
雖然我們設定
在
負100的時候要停損
但
如果我們不停損
有大約一半的機會變成負兩倍
然後另外一半的機會是變成沒輸沒贏的話
那大部分的人
以快樂來說
是會倾向於比較
想不停損
因為
從負100
變成負200
你增加的
不快樂
增加的幅度是比較小的
但如果你本來是負100
變成
沒輸沒贏的話
那你減少的不快樂是多很多的
也就是說
你增加的快樂是多很多的
也就是說如果
你沒有辦法
嚴格的制定一套規則
讓你自己能夠嚴格的執行
停損跟停利的話
那人類會
很容易
變成是
一個提早停利
但是不停損的狀態
也就是說
人性會讓人
更容易長期的持有
正在虧錢的資產
那如果一個資產正在賺錢的話
他會更容易把這個資產給賣掉
好
那這個就是
因為剛剛
我們學習的這些
因為
邊際效益遞減
因為展望理論
因為
Genceing Equality
我們可以
知道
人類都會犯一樣的錯誤
在收益增加的時候
快樂增加的很少
然後
損失增加的時候
痛苦的放大也很少
所以我們會
自然而然的
太早停利
然後
太晚停順
這個跟我們剛剛說的
規則一是完全背道而馳的
在數學上來說
強者很容易
平均來說更容易越強
比較弱的
平均更容易越弱
所以如果一個資產比較強的話
平均來說我們更應該繼續持有它
而不是
更傾向於不持有它
好
那這個是
不停損比停損更快樂
提早停利落袋為安
比持續持有更快樂
就是我有看過有一些
這個交易者
他們這個
主要主打就是
不用停損的交易
更快樂
那
當然這句話是對的嘛
這是更快樂
但不一定更能賺錢
好
那就是
我們再貼一次這個
哲學的問題
投資是為了
賺錢還是為了快樂
就是
大部分人
投資的時候
他們心裡想的都是
我要賺錢
然後再把這些賺錢
轉換為快樂
結果
但是他們在投資的過程當中
他們本身就
自然而然的會想要追尋
更高的快樂
反而
投資股市變成是一種
娛樂花費
這樣的話
當然就跟原本的目的
是不太相同
好
那
就是我們
接下來還會
繼續學習很多的
行為經濟學的偏誤
那這些行為經濟學的
就是預測
人類必定會犯的各式各樣的偏誤呢
可以讓你在
遇到這些情況
然後你正要做出這些決策
你很想要提早停歷
很想要提早
不停損的時候
你會知道正在發生什麼事情
然後你有可能可以避免這些錯誤
當然
也並不是
你知道就可以避免這些錯誤
還要有更多的制度來
執行
好那
大家都知道嘛
台股
大漲
就是
從
一萬多點
就突然大暴漲
漲到三萬多點
但是
事實上呢
在網路上可以看到
很多的人
他們
持有的股票
其實加總
還是虧錢的
當然
我可以理解
有很多
華人思想人
他們會覺得說
如果你有一個好東西
你不應該
分享
教別人
因為在
中國古代可能有很多
他們那種街頭賣藝的
或者說那種
傳承的老師傅
他們
整個門派最重要的
就是
某一個秘訣
如果這個秘訣被
別人知道
他們
幾乎整個門派就沒有任何的
互承核或競爭優勢
但是
現在這個時代
要學習各種東西
都是非常容易的
而且每一個人應該是很容易
學會非常非常多很厲害的事
所以
就是
從我以前打
爐石戰技的時候
我就會
做馬克洋超牌大拳
就是
我打上
這個伺服器第1的牌組
我也是很
開心的讓大家超
那如果
我在天梯上遇到另外一個
超我牌組的對手
然後用跟我一樣
超我的牌組打敗我
我也會覺得很開心
這個就是
讓整個世界
不停的進步的一個動力
那
就是事實上
我最一開始
開直播
不是開遊戲直播
是我大學的時候
因為我是讀醫學系
那醫學系的人大部分
是不太會數學的
那所以
我在寫微積分作業的時候
大家都會想要問我
那我如果
就是要
分別的教很多個同學
這個
數學作業怎麼寫
的話很麻煩
所以我乾脆我每次
這個
寫完作業之後
我就開直播
我講這一次的那個
微積分作業要怎麼寫
那大家
如果要問我
我就可以貼直播連結給他
他們就可以直接
就是方便的
這個超我的作業
好
我只是在講說
就是
很多人會覺得說
有賺錢的方法
怎麼可能會
想要分享給別人
不是
我們這個傳統華人
都是你有
學會了一點好東西
你就是不要告訴
其他人嗎
確實我在
我知道
有一些私立學校
他們
的同學是
如果你拿到了一份
這個
斷考或什麼的考古題的話
你要不分享給同學
因為
這個如果同學
他分數提升了
他變成全班第一名
你就拿不到全班第一名
但是
事實上
這個世界
這個地球上的人
是非常非常多的
就是我跟
我
國中
就是我們那時候
李化克蠻特別的
我們的李化克
那個李化老師
就是蠻混的
他的做法是
就是給每一個
小朋友同學
就是
大家都每個人買一本
參考書
然後自己看參考書
自己寫題目
那如果
有什麼問題的話
再去前面
這個私下問老師
然後
那個老師
大部分的時候
都在看股票
真的蠻帥的
他就是坐在前面
然後一直看股票
大家有問題自己走去前面問他
那
同學
因為我們是數理班嘛
其實大部分小朋友
自我學習能力也都蠻強的
那所以
大家就自己看一看
他如果不會
通常就問同學就可以了
然後
跟我
同
同桌的一個同學
他叫
謝忠林
這是我國中的同學
後來我們都分別在
不同年份拿到
奧林匹亞的金牌
就是
某個考試遊戲的世界冠軍
考試奧運的
就是
我們
雖然
互相進步了
我如果全翻第一名的時候
他就沒辦法全翻第一名
但是
我們也不是為了說
爭奪這個
小小的區域
局部的第一名
我們應該是大家一起進步
然後爭奪這個整個地球的排名
甚至或者是
更厲害的像伊隆馬斯克他覺得
這個帶領全人類一起進步
我們爭奪我們在這個銀河系裝中的排名
好
那我們繼續講就是
處分效應是說
大部分的人長期是輸錢
是因為
就是
人性跟市場的方向會做出完全相反的事情
我們很容易
提早的停利
然後太晚的停順
如果有很多正在賺錢的股票
那這個
他賺錢就反而會很想要把他落袋為安賣掉
因為很多人會想說
如果我每一個股票
都在賺5%
或是譬如說賺10%的時候賣掉
那
沒有賣的就不算虧嘛
所以
在我整個股市生涯裡
我買的每一支股票
最後都是賺5%或賺10%的
那當然還有很多
這個還沒有賣掉的是
這個
浮虧
但是因為
沒賣就不算虧嘛
那所以那些就不算
那
這個
就是
人性會很容易
產生這樣的想法
那這也不是因為
就是說
人類就是非常的純
是因為
後面還有
會講很多嘛
就是
心理賬戶啊
任列虧損啊
就是
這些原因
都是
非常的合理
非常有
數學上的邏輯跟原因的
好
所以我們就簡單講一個
這個
就是
行為經濟學課本上就很容易
寫到的一個
反人性策略
那我自己也可以把他命名為
反處分效應
因為
前面那個叫做
Disposition effect
我們就把他寫成
Anti-Disposition effect
那如果是
這個
聽起來更爽的話
就是反人性策略
因為大部分人就會覺得說
我們這個市場要做
一件反人性的事情
這樣就覺得自己
特立獨行
跟大家不一樣
覺得自己很棒
那簡單來說呢
就是每隔一段時間
那通常的建議是
每半年或者是
每一個季度
那每半年的話是
我認為是一個
還不錯的時間間隔
那這個每隔一段時間
也不能夠
太頻繁
例如說每一個禮拜
那這樣當然就不好
因為
股票的交易成本
其實是非常非常高的
那當然這也是
為什麼
交易期貨在
90%以上的情況
都比交易現股更好的原因
因為
就是現股的
交易成本是
遠遠遠遠遠遠遠遠
交易期負的
對於
交易期貨的
交易成本是遠遠遠遠
低於交易現股的
而且是差距非常非常多倍
好
那所以
大約啦
就是說你可以設定
這個
每年的
2月和8月
或者是幾月跟幾月
那你就
檢視你的整個股票清單
然後
這個非常簡單
你就把
所有
正在虧錢
水下的股票
全部都賣掉
然後換成
賺錢的那些股票
那可能你一開始是
選了
10支或是20支的股票
然後後來你的股票就越來越集中
越來越集中
這個是
我從
2022年跟群益期貨演講的時候
就有講的策略
如果
執行這件事情的話
你有可能很自然而然
最後你的股票
就會只剩下
比如說台積電
或者是一些
就是在這幾年表現非常
誇張非常好的
這些股票
好
那當然實際上
我自己的
這個執行的交易策略是
更具體更完整
我只是
講述
在書上很容易提到的
跟
處分效應相對
我們很容易
執行
而且
這麼簡單的事情
就可以讓
你的績效大為提升
可能本來
你賺的
只是跟
通貨膨脹率差不多
就已經可以
輕微打敗大盤的一個方式
好
然後
接下來我要講的
這個概念是
這場演講很重要的
就是說呢
我在
拉斯維加斯的所有高額賭場
他們都禁止我玩21點
然後甚至有些賭場也禁止我玩
百家樂和其他一些撲克牌遊戲
他們禁止我玩
這些遊戲不是因為他們看出來我是一個
賭博摩世務的數學天才
是因為
賭場
用
他們收集到的數據
然後確認了這個人
他是建立了一套完整的制度跟策略
而且他很穩定的有紀律的在執行這些策略
也就是說這就變成是一個
賭場無法擊敗的玩家
所以賭場就會不歡迎你來玩
也就是說
就是
要能夠長期穩定賺錢的重點是
建立一套
明確的制度跟體系
然後用科學化的
風險控管和情緒管理制度讓你可以
穩定的執行這一套制度跟體系
而不是說
就是
你變成一個很強很聰明然後很有臨場反應的人
然後看到這個盤然後你就臨場反應的
這個決定要做什麼事情
就是
實際上
要穩
成為一個穩定賺錢
不只是21點
就是各式各樣的金錢遊戲裡面
穩定獲利的玩家
事實上他是一個
就是重複的執行
很
重複的事情的一件事
就是
他並不是
股市交易不是像那個
那種
鬥志漫畫裡面
然後看到說
嘿
這個試戳
哇這個戳一個漲停
但是呢
我
預判了你的預判
然後
這個我早就知道你會抽單
然後在你快要抽單的前一刻
我就下單
然後看到你抽單
然後就說
嗯
你說謊了唷
不是像漫畫這樣子
實際上
我們執行這些策略是
一個很
很機械性的
不停的重複一樣事情的過程
就是
現在我們看到什麼樣的狀態
所以我們就
要放多少的籌碼
然後
發出了什麼牌
我們就固定執行什麼樣的動作
那它是有一個
其實
其實21點真的很簡單
21點大概就是
像是被一個
19乘19乘發表的
這樣的一個表格
然後再配上很多的
這個制度
那
或許這邊有一些人有
這個
學習過我的21點
課程嗎
我看到有一些學員
今天有來聽
好
就是我們
執行這些東西
事實上最重要的是
能不能夠穩定的執行一個賺錢的
體系跟制度
而不是
這個是一個
臨場反應的天才
然後
這個靠著強大的經驗跟什麼
人性跟人性之間的心理博弈
就是
實際上
沒有這麼有趣
好
那當然
這件事情
困難的地方
其實是在於
建立這些制度
那當然是
這個我們現在這個時代是很容易槓桿別人的
知識的嘛
那例如說
我或者是其他
這個成功的交易者
建立了一套制度
那你們可能就可以
學習
然後
就是想辦法
照著執行就可以了
好
那也順便講一下
就是
有錢人或是成功的人
他們
跟普通人的差異
最大的差異就是
學會使用槓桿
那槓桿的話有三種
第一種就是
槓桿別人的壽命
哇這聽起來非常的
這個
沉重啊
但是
事實上
老闆
請你去當他的員工
他就是在槓桿你的壽命
哇聽起來真的很邪惡
但是因為
人類的壽命都是有限的
那如果一個人他可以使用別人的壽命的話
他就更容易賺到很多的錢嘛
例如說一個老闆
他可能
有一萬個員工
那這一萬個員工都同時在幫他賺錢
同時在幫他
也不一定是賺錢
也可以是生產
也可以是達到
例如說
贏得選舉
或者是得到更高的權力
或者是
完成某一個成就
比如說蓋出一個火箭
那反正就是槓桿別人的壽命
這是一個
很重要的因為大家的壽命都是幾乎一樣長的
那第二個就是槓桿別人的知識
那在現在這個時代
槓桿別人的知識就是
在歷史的場合裡面大家都
科學家、數學家
當然也有
這個其他的家
他們都
已經
讓人類的科技
進展了一些
如果我們可以
學習到他們
的知識的話
當然是非常好的
那當然
也不一定要買課程
你可以
最簡單的就是買書
然後或者在現在這個時代呢
我們就是可以
跟AI學習
事實上也是
可以大幅的增加
學習的效率
我在
很多年前有
這個
就是
建立推出了一套方法
叫做
如何在各個領域
快速的成為大師
那當然這個
也是我能夠同時
做很多事情
學習很多事情
而且
在大部分遊戲裡面
有一些可以拿到
這個亞洲第一啊
世界第一或者是至少拿到
前1%
前5%的原因
就是在各個領域
快速學習快速成為大師的一些方法
那
這個在現在這個時代呢
就比以前再更方便很多了
現在我
常常就是
都是一直不停的跟
AI對話來學習
事實上我學21點也是
沒有
特定的跟任何一個人類學
我
主要就是
請TradeGPT幫我在網路上
查各種資料
然後
請他幫我寫一些Python
然後做一些模擬
然後我就可以
當然
這個是
這種
自學到
自學21點
這種難度的話
需要匯一點點數學
就是因為
實際上AI有時候會
給出一些錯誤的資訊
或是給出一些錯誤的計算
那我可以馬上快速的知道說
那你在這邊有一個計算的錯誤
這個會稍微難一點
不過大部分的知識
跟AI學習都是
至少非常有效率
而且非常快速的
好
然後
我的整個交易體系
當然第一個就是
長線持有很多的多大部分部位
再來就是
短線的事件交易跟遊戲漏洞
那這個也算是
我自己的一個特色吧
就是
我很擅長
玩各式各樣的遊戲
而且
可能是我
小時候成長背景
就是我會覺得
這個遊戲規則
通常都是可以被
穩定的
公平的
符合公平正義的
實際執行的
當然
股票市場跟美國的
高額賭場
也幾乎是可以達到這個
地步
尤其是美國的高額賭場
他們都是有嚴格的
這個反
第三方的反作弊監控
那所以
就是
就算我
玩一個遊戲漏洞
贏了賭場很多錢
他們都是
可以很
誠實的
這個
支付我
但如果是什麼
線上娛樂層
或者是
地下的非法賭場
那
他們是沒有任何的信用成本的
就是如果一個
非法娛樂層
他
在
玩
你說線上白家樂
你只要eo in
他就播影片給你看
然後把你的錢全部引走
就算你發現他的作弊
他其實就把網站關掉
然後再
再換一個新的網站就可以了
那當然地下賭場更是這樣
就是
在
台灣
實際上
很多事情都還是要靠黑道來敲
如果你不是背景非常的
有背景的人的話
那其實就算別人炸賭你
你也不一定能夠把那錢拿回來
所以
就是
雖然啊
我是
就是有
玩很多各式各樣的金錢遊戲
但是
我都是
必須要確定在
這些規則能夠被
明確的執行的地方
才能夠玩這些遊戲
例如說美國的賭場
或者是台灣的股市
當然台灣股市
是可以賴皮作弊
做一些內線交易什麼的
這個是
稍微犯規但是不會被抓的情況
這樣子
好
就是主要是跟大家說
如果是那種什麼線上娛樂層
或是非法的博弈
盡量
都是
就算你有一個很好的數學策略
也不要去那邊執行
因為
就是
最簡單
他們也不一定要作弊
他們可以就
不出金不付錢給你嘛
譬如說你去
地下賭場算牌
你算牌贏了錢
之後他就說
你怎麼這樣子
你這樣
好那我不付你錢
這樣的話你就拿不到錢了
好
反正我是
非常擅長的做這些
遊戲漏洞的發現
然後
還有事件交易
那
這些
短線交易的話
也分成很多不同的類型
就是例如說攻擊別人的程式單
有一些是
遊戲規則上必然會發生的事情
然後
好
我以前的
講座我都是
都是直接
直接講那個策略
但是因為現在
跟群益起貨合作
我還是要
這個
就是有一些
投顧的
產品跟教學
所以現在好像是
不能夠直接
講太多
好但是我們都還是會講
還是會把
今天啦
主要是會講
這個掃書這一部分
至少這一部分是
很重要
然後
而且
很值得學習的
就是
如果你在整個
交易的過程當中
你的生涯裡面
大部分人應該都有
爆掉過一次的經驗
如果你可以
少爆掉一次10萬塊
甚至少爆掉一次50萬塊
那
你
整個人生少爆掉一次
其實你就等於是
多了非常多的錢
那
在掃書這邊
就是有行為經濟學
風險控制
還有這些
情緒管理制度
那
這些制度
它不是為了限制現在的你
而是為了限制未來的你
就是
如果
你可以開始
不需要
依循著自己的
盤感或是自己的創意來做這些
金錢投資的決定的話
實際上你的表現是會好非常多
好
那這是
我的一個
期貨的學生
他跟我說了一個有趣的事情
就是
他在做交易的決策
或是投資的決策的時候
如果他不知道該怎麼做的時候
他就會想說
如果
現在是馬克洋的話會怎麼做
那如果最後賠錢的話
那就是馬克洋的問題
就是因為這是馬克洋做的決定
如果賺錢的話
那這是我判斷真的是太棒了
對
就居然做了這麼好的決定
這個也是一個
這個
在
在行為經濟學裡面的一種
偏誤的一個很好的使用
就是
如果發生了好的事情
那就是自己很棒
如果發生了不好的事情
那都是別人的錯
好
那這個也是一個很好的方式
就是
猶豫的時候
就問馬克洋會怎麼做
好
那
就是
控制
控制自己
不要去犯這些行為經濟學的錯誤
並不是說
我們應該要控制自己的貪念
控制心魔
心態很重要
很多
的這個
就是
他寫了一大篇的交易文章
然後就是在說
這個心魔真的很可怕
可是
就是
完全不知道
那
所以具體是要怎麼控制
這個心魔具體又是怎麼運作的
那我們要怎麼樣子
減少這樣的情況發生
也都完全沒有
所以
就是
我們還是需要
一套制度
然後用行為經濟學來
設計這些東西
我們才能夠
真正的
減少我們的犯錯
好
那我們
接下來會講
很多很多的
行為經濟學
就是
行為經濟學解決的是真實世界的問題
第一個
這個
一個有趣的事情就是
不停損的當衝科
我們
剛已經知道了嘛
就是人性會傾向於
不停損跟提早停歷
那如果是
這個
當衝然後使用保證金減半或者是
就是
選當衝的話
很有可能
他們在尾盤的時候
是會被強迫一定要平倉的
就是不能夠留倉的
所以
如果是在一個
大漲
一路大漲
和一路大跌的盤
然後
現在是
這個
1點半了
那在最後15分鐘的話
平均來說
你在接近
1點44分
我說的是期貨
就是
1點44分出的話
有可能是會比
1點半出更好的
因為
在最後會有一小段
例如說今天是大漲500點
或大跌500點
之後
最後會有一小段燃料
他們是
不停損的人
他們必須要在尾盤的時候
被強迫停損
那這個就是
這個
在行為經濟學裡面
你學習到一些知識
然後你就可以
得出一些猜想
然後在實際數據上面
去驗證這些猜想
好那就是
知道別人會做什麼
就可以用策略讓別人支付你
那當然除了這個
行為經濟學
還有一種
類型的就是
攻擊別人的程式單
如果
你知道這個
市場上
有很多的
程式單或很多的人
他們都在
根據什麼事情
去進行
什麼樣的決定的話
那
既然你知道他們會做什麼
那你
就可以提早一步的去攻擊他們
那當然也不只是程式單啦
像是
我之前
這幾年
講過很多次的
就是
NSCI
跟富士調整日
那
這個也是
知道
巨金
知道這些巨額資金
他們會做什麼
那也可以讓
這些巨額資金在這些
調整日的過程當中
強迫一定要支付你
因為
這些調整日就是
這些巨額資金
他們
被強迫
一定要在某個時間點
做出了某個
動作
所以其實
實際上
在股市裡面
就是
錢很少的人
是很容易
賺錢很多的人的便宜的
就是因為
錢很多的人
他們
要移動
要翻身
要
做一點點動作
他們都沒有辦法
突然做一個很大的動作
他們在做那個動作
會有一個過程
那在他們開始做那些動作
或是他們強迫一定要做那個動作的時候
那
這些
這個小蝦米就很容易可以去
吃到他一點東西
這樣
好啊
這個就是
知道別人會做什麼
就可以讓別人
用策略讓別人支付你
好
那我們
講一個
行為經濟學在日常生活中的應用
那當然這個故事也是非常寓意深遠的
就是
計程車司機的上班策略
那我在搭計程車的時候
有時候就會跟這些計程車司機聊天
然後
我有時候會問他們說
那你
你平常一天是要跑多久
就是要開多久的車
那你是怎麼決定你一天要開多久的車
那比較常見的話
有兩種
計程車司機他們的
決定要開多久的車
第一個是
他們決定自己每天固定要跑多少時間
例如說
固定禮拜幾禮拜幾他就是跑8個小時
禮拜幾禮拜幾他就是
開車開6個小時
這是固定時間的策略
那
也有一些人他們是固定金額
例如說
我
開一天開到賺3000塊
我就回家休息
那
如果今天還沒有賺到3000塊
那我就先
先繼續開
開到賺3000塊為止
那實際上呢
這兩個策略都還不夠好
其實更好的策略是
他應該要
設定一個時間
例如說
我今天開車的前三個小時
如果賺的比我平均更多錢
那我就應該要再開車開更長的時間
如果呢
我現在
今天
在
開的前三個小時賺的錢比平均更少
平均前三個小時更少
那
我今天就提早回家休息
那這可能會有很多的原因嘛
例如說今天實際上
有一個演唱會
或者是
馬克強在這邊辦演講
有500個人來
那
就是他
他
不可能去研究這些事情嘛
在擅長的時候
你們500個人都要同時
走出去
那可能這個計程車的流量就會
需求會突然增加
那
或者是說
就是
今天可能是天氣不好
或者是
有什麼樣的活動
就是這些原因都是不需要知道的
但是
如果你在前幾個小時
是賺比較多錢的
那你在接下來幾個小時
在這個局部也更容易賺更多錢
當然反過來也是完全一樣的
這個就跟股票的趨勢是一樣的
就是
趨勢基本上是很容易
比較容易延續的
就是
強者更容易更強
弱者更容易更弱
所以你在前幾個小時賺更多的錢
在下一個小時
平均來說是更容易賺更多的錢
那當然實際上
計程車司機應該是沒有人使用這樣的策略
這就是一個
非常數學的策略
那這也跟我們剛剛
前面講的很類似
就是
更長的持有正確的倉位
更短的持有錯誤的倉位
如果
一件事情正在賺錢
那你就應該
盡量不要改變它
讓這件賺錢的事情
繼續持續下去
如果一件事情它正在
失敗
它正在虧錢
那你就應該要更快的停止它
好
那再來講一個
這個
行為經濟學的騙物
叫做控制錯覺
Illution of control
就是人類會高估自己對隨機結果的影響
或者是預測能力
那
這個
就是
百家樂
他們現在的百家樂
旁邊都會
有一個螢幕
然後那個螢幕會記錄
在整條牌的
前面
每一把的輸贏
然後它會
紀錄用很多種不同的方式
然後把它紀錄在上面
這個叫做
錄單顯示器
就是
這個是賭場
一個
劃時代的
礦室發明
在以前
賭場的百家樂
是沒有辦法賺這麼多錢的
但是
後來
某一個
心理學家
天才
他發明了這個
錄單顯示器
這錄單顯示器
會記錄
例如說
前面是莊家營
賢家營
莊家營
那
他就會
巧妙地利用到
這個
控制錯覺
就是
人類會
高估自己對隨機結果的影響
或控制能力
如果
例如說前面
前幾場是
三個紅
會配一個藍
然後又出現三個紅
再配一個藍
那如果這個
三紅一藍
連續出現三次之後
可能
很多人就會覺得說
那接下來會再出現三個紅
然後再出現一個藍
但實際上
這顯然是一件非常荒謬的事情
就是
百家樂是
有一點接近5050
就是莊家
稍微
機率高一點點
因為補牌是不對稱的
但是
我們就簡化
把它當做一個
接近5050的事情
那
下一把的結果
跟前面的結果都是
完全
沒有關聯
而且是
非常接近一半一半的
但是呢
因為illusion of control
所以
當
某一顆
就是
他說一顆
就是說
在下一把牌
如果同時在很多條路
就是他有各種
不同的紀錄方式
在
很多條路
他都很符合
某一個 pattern
某一個規則的話
好
那
很可能
就會
直接
All in自己
桌上全部的錢
甚至有的人
他們就是真的
All in自己
全部的身家
而且
百家樂這個遊戲
他
讓
很多
人性
自然而然的
發展出來的
正常遊玩方式
就是All in
就是如果有些人有
看過別人玩
百家樂
或是知道
百家樂這個遊戲的話
就是在百家樂這個遊戲裡面
正常的玩法就是All in
這真的非常的猛
所以
大部分
百家樂的玩家
他們的
risk of ruin
就是破產機率
都是
幾乎接近100%的
那
當然這也是講說
就是盡量不要玩這個遊戲
這個遊戲真的是
會輸到傾家蕩產的遊戲
那他巧妙的利用呢
就是這個
Illution of control
就是
人會高估
自己對隨機結果的影響
或者是預測能力
為什麼人類會
特別容易接受
技術分析的原因
就是
技術分析
會讓人有一種
自己是有在
預測的
一個錯覺
那
但是如果
那個技術分析
它並不是
經過非常嚴謹的
統計學
或者是有數學的
背後的原因的話
那
事實上啦
絕大多數的技術分析
都是超級白癡
超級沒有用的策略
好
人會很喜歡
技術分析的另外一個原因
叫做
模糊厭物
ambiguity aversion
就是人會偏好
已經知道機率的風險
比較不喜歡
未知機率的不確定性
那這個書上很常會講的這個故事
就是這個
艾爾斯柏格悖論
如果
現在有一個袋子
然後這個袋子裡面呢
有100個紅球
然後有200個
黑球或黃球
黑球加黃球
加起來是200個
但是我們不知道它的比例
然後
現在呢
就是讓你進行一個遊戲
就是
你抽其中一顆球
那如果
抽到的球是你猜的那個顏色的話
你就會
贏得一筆獎金
例如說100萬
那
紅球是佔全部的三分之一
黑球跟黃球加起來是
佔三分之二
那我們就一樣
做一個有趣的調查好了
就是
如果抽到的那顆球是你猜的那個顏色的話
然後可以贏100萬的話
你會
比較想要
猜
確定機會是三分之一的紅球的舉手
好
那
你會比較想要
猜
機率是零到三分之二之間某一個數字的黑球的舉手
好
看起來大部分的人是不想要參與這個
可以賺100萬的遊戲
這是非常特別
這個
告訴我們說華人是非常
害羞不喜歡舉手的
幾乎每一次
做這種調查遊戲都會得出這個結論
另外一個相對的地方
我們就
不進行
這麼冗長的舉手環節
看起來大家也不太喜歡舉手
那另外一個選項是
就是
你要猜
是中
黃球或黑球的其中一個
會贏100萬
還是
黃球加黑球他們加起來
就確定是三分之二的機會
然後還是
黃球加紅球
就是一個不確定的機率
可以贏100萬
那
會有
比較多人
會在第一個選擇裡面
他們會選擇
紅球
因為
是確定三分之一
或者是一個問號的機率
那在下面這個選項呢
也會比較多人選擇
確定三分之二的機率
超過
也一個問號的機率
但是實際上呢
這兩個選項是
完全一樣的選項
就是
紅球加黃球加黑球
加起來是全部的球嘛
所以
就是紅球
選紅球就是等於
不選黃球加黑球
然後選
黑球就是
等於不選黃球加紅球
所以
如果你是
比較想要選
紅球的話
那就是
比較有可能是
當然實際上你心裡不是這樣想的
不過數學家
就是可以把它列成這樣
就是
那就是
紅球
會
傾向大於
黑球的比例
但是在下面這個選項裡面的話
就變成
紅球的傾向
不大於黑球的比例
也就是說在這兩個選項裡面
人的
對於
黑球
會不會平均來說
超過紅球的
心理傾向是相反的
當然實際上
我們沒有辦法知道
紅球跟黑球哪一個比較多
但是
我們可以得出一個結論
就是說
人類是
比較不喜歡
不確定的
機率的
好
那這也是
人性特別容易接受
技術分析的
其中一個原因
那
技術分析實際上
大部分
的
技術分析都是
超級白癡
就例如說
畫斜的軌道線
這個是一個
超級常見
但是超級白癡的事情
就是
一開始是有畫
水平的線嘛
那水平的線
是真的
表示了有很多的人
在這個價格帶裡面
成交
所以確實
經過那個價格的時候
會發生一些
特定的事情
因為
更多的人的持倉成本
是在那邊
但如果你是畫一個
斜的軌道線的話
那
它是完全沒有任何數學意義的
就是
它純粹就是
讓你
讓你畫了一條線
就只是這樣子而已
沒有發生任何事情
那
當然
他們
如果是要
碼後泡盤後解盤的話
他們很容易就可以畫說
你看
在這個地方
我畫這個斜的軌道線
碰到了
然後這邊
疊回來了
那所以
這個
確實嘛
你看
碰到這個軌道邊緣
就轉折回來
如果
在
後面一點點的地方看到
你看碰到那個線之後
出去
這個就是
突破了
突破的話
你看就一路上去了
那就
等於是完全沒有任何的預測能力
也沒有解決任何的精準度的問題
但是
還是會有很多人喜歡看這樣的技術分析
因為
看技術分析會讓人很容易覺得有道理
雖然他們沒有
提高準確性
但是他們降低了那個模糊的感覺
那就滿足了大家
這個模糊厭惡和illusion of control的這個
這個人性的感覺
好
那
接下來講了這個
這個人性的偏誤
跟心理丈夫有些關係
然後他也是
很容易讓人一次
把全部贏的錢都輸回去
大輸特輸的一個原因
就是
人類很容易覺得
剛贏來的錢
還不是自己的錢
這個是
賭場的錢
或是
股市送我的錢
賭場
從賭場贏來的錢
輸回去比較沒關係
反正輸不到本金
這個就是跟心理帳戶有關係
就是
實際上你擁有的每一塊錢
他都是一塊錢
那不會因為這一塊錢他是
屬於
XXX的一塊錢
或圈圈圈的一塊錢
那你就可以用
不一樣的風險偏誤來對待他
那
或者是說輸回去比較沒有關係
好
那
這個也是
其中一個原因
為什麼
我在
拉斯維加斯的這些高額賭場
他們已經禁止我玩牌了
但是
他們還是繼續讓我免費住
四個月高級的房間
甚至
幾乎啦
如果你在高額區
贏了錢
但是又
被判定為優勢玩家
禁止你玩之後
他們很可能還是會提供你
免費的高級住宿
當然
他讓你免費的
住在高級套房
實際上他們的成本
邊際成本
是非常非常低的
因為
賭場這些
很漂亮的房間
幾乎永遠都是不會是住滿的
所以
他雖然不給你住也是空房
那
他確定你手上有這麼多的
現金
那
他讓你免費住在這邊
只要
這些免費住在這邊的人
其中
有一些人
他們覺得說
這個是賭場的錢
那我下去
玩一玩百家樂
丟一丟骰子
這個玩一玩輪盤
輸回去
要買就是輸回去
要買就是翻倍
那
這些賭場遊戲
如果你是
不是優勢的遊戲的話
都是富期望值的
那你很容易就可以
這個
就是
把這些錢輸回去
所以
事實上
他們
在
不給
優勢玩家玩21點的時候
並不是像
這個電影裡面演的
就是
說
你搞什麼東西
然後把你拖出去
然後
之後後面一堆黑人都出來
然後把你暴揍一頓
就不是這樣子
實際上是
他們會很客氣的
說
這個
you're too good for this game
就是說
你
我們很客氣的
跟你說
你可能
我們不適合繼續讓你玩
Blackjack
但是啊
我們旁邊有百家樂啊
這個百家樂也很好玩啊
要不你去旁邊丟丟骰子玩玩輪盤呢
就是
他們都很客氣
然後還會請一個那個host來說
啊
這個
謝謝你來玩啊
你賭這麼大
我也是送你幾天的漂亮的房間
然後你吃東西也盡量吃也都是免費的
就是
因為
這個是house money effect嘛
他確定你手上有籌碼
而且
你剛贏到這些籌碼
剛贏到這些籌碼的時候
你是很容易覺得
輸回去沒有關係的
然後你看人家又那麼親切
然後我就去玩個兩把吧
那很容易就把錢輸回去
這是house money effect
那另外
這個
這個故事啊
現在可以講是因為他
現在後來又把大部分錢贏回來
不然的話我以前也不太
敢講這個故事
就是
我有一個期貨的學生
他
在半年之內
他用300萬就贏到1500萬
然後
當然是這個絕對是run good的
就是運氣非常好的情況
然後
畢竟我們執行數學策略本來就是會有run good跟run bad的時候嘛
他就覺得說
我都贏1500萬
我就把300萬的本金
出金取出來
那接下來的
這些錢
不管怎麼樣玩我都輸不到我的本金嘛
但事實上
這個是一個
很多
傳統華人會
覺得很好
這樣的話
你這個不貪喔
很好
觀念很好
但實際上這是一個
非常不好的想法
因為
就等於是
你把這些剩下來的錢
用
不一樣的風險偏誤去對待他
那
當然這件事情也跟
這個
ROR risk of ruin有關
就是
他認為
台積電
一定會上1500
所以他決定
就是永遠都開
最高的槓桿
槓爆
如果
這1500萬
當時台積電
可能不到1000
然後
如果也可以一路漲到1500的話
哇
他就直接
賺爆賺爛了
結果呢
剛好
遇到川普
對全地球
加超爆高的關稅
然後
全地球股市就暴跌
但是
我們群組的
大家都跟他說
你不應該繼續做這樣的事情
因為這樣的話
你的risk of ruin
就是
輸光這一份錢的風險會太高
就算它是一個
正期望值的事情
但是如果你的下注尺度太大
你的槓桿太高的話
你的
這個
就是輸光你這一份錢的機率
仍然會非常非常高
就是
你的下注尺度如果超過凱利公式
的建議的話
事實上
在數學上
資金長期翻倍的速度反而是下降的
也就是說
並不是
一個策略是正期望值
你就應該要盡量下得更大
或者是
使用更大的槓桿
事實上
這個世界是一個重複的遊戲
並不是說
你生涯只會做一次投資
所以如果你在這一次
資金變少的話
是會影響你未來的收益的
這個是另外一個關於
破產機率
Risk of ruin的概念
就是
當然這邊講的是說
就是因為他
會覺得
這個錢是賭場的錢
就是這是贏來的錢
我把我本金都出出去了
那這1000多萬
輸的也是
還好也是沒有關係嘛
所以他就有可能反而在這個正期望值的情況下
然後
大家都勸他說真的不要再做這樣的事情
反而他
這個就快速的
就是幾乎在川普關稅那一次一次就
把賺了1500萬全部輸回去
當然他也是真的有
用親身的教訓學習到這些事情
後來他也就是
改變了很多
然後使用
非常有紀律的穩定的執行
然後現在也把大部分
師徒都收復了
所以我才敢講這個故事
不然的話
也會覺得
這個講的話有點太
就是
不太敢講
好
然後
因為講的話幾乎就可以辨識出是誰啊
所以就是
就是不太不太敢講
好然後
這就是賭場的錢效應
然後
也不只是
特定的一個學生
事實上
我在交
21點
或者是期貨
或者是在
很多的這些金錢遊戲
都有看過很多的人
例如說他算牌
然後
可能
很
例如說一個禮拜
算牌就贏了兩三百萬
或者是
怎樣
他可能就會
更容易覺得這些錢
我可能去丟個骰子
或什麼
玩百家了
就是
就是好玩
輸掉了也沒關係
因為那不是自己的錢
就是
這種事情是
實際上很
很常發生
很容易發生的
因為這就是
人性很容易讓人會犯的錯誤
好
那這件事情跟
心理賬戶也很有關係
就是心理賬戶說的是
我們對待
自己的每一塊錢
的
風險偏好
或者是
決策方式
會很容易
因為
我們覺得這一塊錢
是屬於哪裡
所以才
做出了完全不一樣的決定
好
那
講一個
之前也有講過的一個故事
就是
如果
有一個學生他可能
很喜歡周杰倫
然後他想要去看周杰倫的演唱會
但是呢
周杰倫的演唱會的門票
一張要一萬塊台幣
哇
那
那很貴吧
就是對學
至少對學生來說
周杰倫演唱會的門票
好像實際上不只一萬台幣
如果要跟黃牛買的話更貴
不過我們簡化
就說一萬好了
就是
那
花一萬塊
學生會覺得說
好像太貴了
買不起
所以
就
就不
不去看那個演唱會
結果呢
在
某一個
幸運的情況下
可能是抽獎
或是有人送他一張
門票
他就免費的得到一張周杰倫演唱會的門票
然後呢
但是
他在
某一個
例如說
我們假設在
網路上很容易的
用一萬塊
賣出
這一張門票
然後也很容易用一萬塊買到這張門票
當然
在台灣這個
買賣黃牛票是違法的
不過我們就是說
實際上如果我們很容易
在網路上
用一萬塊買到這張門票
又很容易用一萬塊賣出這張門票的話
那他有可能在免費抽到這張門票的時候
他決定會
要去看這場演唱會
而不是用一萬塊
把這張門票賣出去
不去看這場演唱會
但是在數學上
他不願意買一張
一萬塊的
演唱會門票
卻又同時
不願意把
一萬塊的門票賣掉
而真的去
看演唱會
數學上是非常矛盾的事情
但是我們
聽了這故事並不會
馬上直覺想到說
怎麼可能有人
不願意用一萬塊買門票
但又不願意用一萬塊把自己的門票賣出去
就是
你平常只會覺得這是一件很正常的事情
不會覺得說
那難道他認為這個演唱會的價值
同時低於一萬塊又高於一萬塊嗎
那你這樣子的話
數學上
不理性不合理啊
就是甚至我們都很不容易想到這件事情
我
就是大家第一次聽到可能都
還需要在紙上列出來一下
才能知道說
原來這個
這個
邏輯矛盾
居然是出現在什麼樣的地方
就是
因為
有可能
一個學生
他的
心理賬戶
他認為
他的娛樂花費
看演唱會的
這個心理賬戶裡面
總共就是只有
例如說
3000塊
那一張門票
一萬塊
那就超過了這個預算嘛
所以
他就沒有辦法去看這場演唱會
但是呢
如果他是免費得到這一張門票
那
那這個是完全沒有超支
這個
每個月的
娛樂心理賬戶的3000塊的額度
那所以他就可以去看這場演唱會
這個就是心理賬戶
就是
在
同樣的一個資產
被歸類在不同心理賬戶的時候
人類會做出不一樣的決定
然後
再來就是
認利的損失
就是
很多人會覺得說
我的股票沒有賣就不虧
例如說
可能會有一個
老先生
他就是
有很多
虧損的股票
就是他的兒子或者是
這個子女就覺得說
你這個這麼多虧損的股票
這樣不好
我就幫你
全部都賣掉
喔
那個
那個老先生可能會非常生氣
他會覺得
你賣掉他的股票這個動作
讓他虧了好幾百萬
因為
在他沒有賣的時候
那就是都沒有虧
但是賣掉那一瞬間
他突然覺得自己虧了好幾百萬
這個也是
這個心理賬戶
認列損失
就是
一個損失還沒有被認列的時候
你會覺得你還沒有損失他
好
然後
另外一個
心理偏誤是
沉默成本
沉默成本指的是
你現在做的決定
不會去改變的
已經發生的事情
就是
例如說
我以前當醫生的時候有一個病人
他
報名了一個三萬塊的網球課程
那
無論他有沒有去打那個網球
他
他有沒有去上那個網球課
那三萬塊都不能夠退費
但是因為他已經網球走了嘛
所以他不適合繼續去打網球
如果他繼續去上網球課的話
他的手會更痛
他的網球軸會更惡化
但是呢
他還是堅持他
要去
上那個網球課
因為他已經付錢了嘛
付錢如果不用的話
感覺就很浪費啊
就是
那個三萬塊的學費就是沉默成本
你現在有沒有繼續去
上那個網球課
那個三萬塊都是固定
一樣已經被付掉了
所以
以傳統經濟學的理性來說
你要不要去打網球
應該只跟
你去上這堂網球課得到的
打網球的快樂
和
讓你的手變得更惡化
得到的痛苦
哪一個
比較
utility比較高
就是快樂的痛苦程度比較高
那所以你就
應該用
純粹這一件事
就是
多去上一堂網球課好不好
而不是
說
考慮學費是多少
來
決定
要不要去打網球
當然我們
如果也問他說
如果這堂網球課是免費的
那是不是
你就
可以不去打
他說
對啊如果是免費的
那就
可以不去打
那這個就是
沉默成本
就是
在行為經濟學的理性上
我們會認為說
人應該要忽略沉默成本
但實際上
人類是沒有辦法忽略沉默成本
好
那這個也是
我很常被問的問題
就是
在台灣
讀醫學系要讀七年
那
讀了七年醫學系之後
又不當醫生
那這個
這個不就是
會覺得很可惜
很浪費嗎
就像你付了三萬塊
去上了一堂網球課
但
實際上
就是我要考慮的應該是
在接下來
我如果繼續當醫生
跟我去做其他事情
那
可以獲得的
各式各樣的效用
不論是賺到了錢啊
獲得了人生快樂啊
能夠達到人生成就啊
都是不一樣的
那
我應該考慮的是
未來
會發生的
各種選擇
我能夠
選出
盡量的
選出裡面
期望來說
最好的一個
那而不是說啊
因為沉默成本啊
你都已經付出了這些成本了
那所以
你就應該要
繼續依循你
以前舊有的路徑
那當然沉默成本也是跟
就是很多的人他
這個就是
可能跟一個很不好的伴侶在一起啊
這個人可能就是
會打他
攻擊他
或是尻掉他很多很多的錢
但是
你也會更不容易跟他分手
就是因為
也很容易覺得說
我都已經花了這麼多年
這麼多的時間
這麼多的精力跟
這個
就是各種資源在他身上了
如果就是分手了
那不是很可惜嗎
好
那就是
沉默成本
就是
以數學理性來說
是
要盡量忽略沉默成本
然後拋開不捨
做出當下最正確的決定
那這個是
叫做不願意買回的正確倉位
就是
我們在執行
長線多單的過程當中
有可能會在當中
會
混合一些短線的空單
那當然這些有可能是避險
也有可能是
純粹的空方策略
那
當然細節原因
就也不是很重要
反正呢
有時候我們在
執行策略過程當中
我們的多單是會短暫的
可能是平倉
就等於是打一個空單
然後再買回來
但是呢
如果
這個空單是停損的話
那
也就是說你需要在
更高一點點的位置
把這個多單買回來
也就是說你可能是
1000塊的時候
把這個倉位賣掉
然後你需要在
1020塊的時候
把它買回來
但是很多人就會覺得說
可是
我1000塊賣掉
如果100020塊買回來
那不就吃虧了嗎
那
還是我乾脆就等
它再跌回1000塊以下
再把它買回來
這樣的話
感覺比較不虧
可是其實這樣就等於是
你的長線繼續執行
但是空單沒有停損嘛
那
這個就是
不願意買回的
正確的倉位
那另外一個是
這個
忘記出的昨日單要怎麼處理
也不一定是要是忘記出
也有
這是
這個是要說的是
無論任何原因
只要你持有了一個
不是你預期的倉位
唯一一個
這個反應就是
馬上把它平倉掉
那無論這個部位是
不小心賺錢還是不小心賠錢
當然不小心賺錢
大家會很容易想要趕快把它平倉掉嘛
因為大家會想要趕快落袋未安
但是
就是如果他
這個不小心進場的倉位
是賠錢的
那
你也要
提醒自己說
就是因為這是一個
隨機的事情
那
他的
賺賠
就算是
接近01V
但是這個也會
大幅的增加你的整個資產波動的方差
就是
增加你整個資產的波動
那所以你也是應該要盡量
快速地把這些非預期的持倉給
馬上的平倉掉
就是無論他是一個
忘記出
或者是沒按到
或者是系統的錯誤
或者是
任何原因
你不小心
進場或是非預期的進場
的倉位出現了
你發現了
就是應該馬上的把它平倉掉
我們今天講了很多的
這個偏誤
就是
這些偏誤都是
人性必然會共同犯的錯誤
那
這些錯誤
會讓我們知道
就是說
我們應該要依循著數學邏輯交易
而不是根據盤感交易
因為
如果根據盤感交易的話
大部分的人
幾乎
都會犯
一樣的錯誤
然後
都會
導致
一樣的
結果
就是
例如說
就算
大漲的時候
他也是有少賺
如果股市虧的時候
贏的時候有少贏
輸的時候反而會多數
那當然這些事情
也都是可以被
這個科學化的制度給解決的
就是
如果你可以制定一套
這個
詳細的制度
科學化的
來控制
會做什麼事情的話
那
也就是可以解決這些人性的問題
好
那
現在幾點了
看不到
好
那這個
接下來是講
秉賦效應
就是
人會過度珍視自己已經擁有的物品
在
這個
行為經濟學裡面
他們原始做的實驗是這樣
就是
他讓很多的學生
他們很多人
都
這個有些人是
擁有一個馬克杯
然後有些人是要去買那個馬克杯
那
大家可以自己的
決定說
我這個馬克杯
價值多少錢
我要賣別人多少錢
然後另外一群人是
決定他要用多少錢
買這個馬克杯
那
可能
平均來說
擁有馬克杯的人會
想要用平均7塊錢來賣出這個馬克杯
但是沒有馬克杯的人會
認為這個馬克杯的價值平均是3塊錢
那3塊錢跟7塊錢就差了
這個兩倍的
估值嘛
也就是說
你會因為你擁有這個馬克杯
本身就
認為這個馬克杯更有價值
那如果你沒有那個馬克杯
你就會覺得這個馬克杯更沒有價值
那這在股票
的也是一樣
就是
如果你持有一檔股票的話
你會更容易傾向於說服自己說
啊我持有的這一檔股票是
是一個很好的股票
那
我應該更常的持有它
那這也會
加強了處置效應
讓你
更不容易就是賣掉你
錯誤的償位
好
那這個
就是
丙複效應
人會過度高估自己擁有物品的價值
那你不願意賣掉
一個股票
的原因是
因為
它是你的
那你就覺得
你自己擁有的東西
這個價值會是更高的
好
然後再來
這個也是很重要的
叫做
就是用結果的好壞來判斷決策是否正確
那這是很容易發生的事情就是
如果
你
沒有辦法真的知道一套數學策略它是不是一個正期望值的正確決定的話
你就很容易用結果的好壞來
衡量你
原本做的決定是不是對的
就例如說
21點
它是一個
玩家優勢的遊戲
但是
如果你
完了幾把牌
反而是輸錢了
那你可能就會覺得說
那看起來我剛剛是做了錯誤的決定
那
甚至
很多很容易發生一件事情就是
如果你做了錯誤的決定
但是反而錯誤的得到了好的結果
這個也是很容易發生的嘛
例如說你做了一個
49%會成功
50%會失敗的事情
那實際上你還是有非常接近一半的情況下
是會不小心成功的
雖然
長期來說這是一個負期望值的決定
但是
因為你可能前面
連續
5次
或是10次
不守紀律
然後做了一個
超出
正期望值策略的
負期望值
行動
但是這些行動
卻多數賺錢了
那你可能就會
反而去干擾
修正自己的系統
覺得說
其實有時候我靈感一下
這個也是很不錯啊
我
你看我這個靈感也是蠻準的嘛
有時候
我靈感一來
這個破壞一下這個策略
反而得到了很好的結果
那這個就是
而且這個是
非常容易
發生的
就是
在
股票
期貨或者是
各種各式各樣的金錢遊戲裡面
都很容易發生
如果你做了一個
錯誤的事情
其實你有接近一半的機會
會得到一個好的反饋
然後
你就會
去加強你的錯誤
把你的錯誤
繼續放大
越來
做越多
繼續你的那個錯誤的事情
好
那
當然這個就是
就是因為
我講的
很多事情都是
如果你剛開始
進行交易
你在未來
你都真實
會
經歷的想法
然後
我們事先的學習它
來避免
降低你
未來
真的遇到這些情況
然後真的去
有這些偏誤的機會
好
那接下來要講的這個是
時間不一致性
就是
同一個人在
不同的時間點
對同一件未來的事情
會很容易做出
不一樣的決策
就是
如果你現在有一個選擇是
你現在馬上
得到100萬
或者是
一年之後再拿到105萬
我們這個還是值得互動一下
那盡量
盡量大部分人都
都舉手
就是
如果現在有兩個選擇
那可能是
你買到了一個資產
或者是
保險單
任何的東西
反正呢
它就是有兩個選項
一個是
你現在可以馬上拿到100萬
跟你一年後拿到105萬
那
這個都沒有對錯
所以大家這個舉手就是
就是
可以
自由一點
就是如果你
你比較想要現在拿到100萬的舉手
這個攝影可以拍一下
這幾乎全部的人都是
都是選擇現在拿到100萬
好
那選擇
一年之後拿到105萬的舉手
好
那這也是有一部分比例的人
就是我設定的是一個
合理的
大概
這個
就是
跟
無風險報酬差不多
就是一年5%的這個收益
那所以你不會覺得說
是一年之後拿300萬
或者是一年之後只拿101萬
那所以賺了或虧了
那
另外一個選擇是
啊
例如說你現在有一個保單
那
你可以選擇是
10年之後拿100萬
或者是
11年之後拿105萬
那多一年之後會
多拿一點點
那
你會比較想要
10年之後拿100萬的舉手
好也是蠻多的人
那你會比較想要
11年之後拿105萬的舉手
好那這個大概就是一半一半
就是
人數
變得差不多
那至少
這個可以看到是說
會
大部分的人都會想要現在拿100萬
然後
一年後拿105萬的人
是少很多的
那
10年跟11年之後這個比例是
蠻接近的
因為
可能它就變成是
你會變成是計算說
那
多了一年
多拿5
那是不是在
一個可以接受的範圍
那通常是
有的人覺得可以
有的人不行嘛
反正它就是一個
一年5%
差不多的報酬
那但是呢
如果
你選擇了
11年之後拿105萬
那
在
經過了10年之後
也就是說
你在某一個時間點
保險公司又
當下又提供了你說
你原本是決定
11年之後拿105萬
但現在已經過10年了
那你可以決定
你要現在拿100萬呢
還是一年之後拿105萬
那就會有
非常多
本來選擇
11年之後拿105萬的人
在第10年的時候
決定
當下現在馬上拿100萬
這個大家應該聽得懂吧
就是說
有非常高比例的人
他們本來選擇
11年之後拿105萬
但是在第10年的時候
他們會改變主意
選擇在第10年的當下
拿100萬
而不是
再等一年拿105萬
而且這個傾向性
在剛剛
謝謝大家
踴躍舉手當中
是可以看到
這兩個問題的傾向
是
差距非常大的
這個原因是因為如果是按照數學的數學家
他們對於如果假設一個人是完美理性的話
那這個人
他對於資產在未來的
這個
效用的折損
應該會是一個固定的比例
譬如說
比如說
過了兩年之後的資產
這個是
0.9倍
然後再過兩年
然後再乘以0.9
再過兩年
再乘以0.9
那它會是一個指數函數的形式
但是實際上
就是
這個藍色的線
Exponential Discounting
就是
如果是一個完美理性的人的話
會是藍色這樣
但是呢
如果是
現實世界的
Human Behaviour的話
它會是一個接近雙曲線
就是
橘色這個
這麼彎曲的情況
它這個彎曲
就是指的是說
在一開始
的價值是降低很多
然後在後來感覺的
價值是
降低的很少
也就是說
如果你是
現在拿
跟一年後拿
你感受到它價值的降低是降低非常多
那如果你在把它弄到更久
例如說
30年拿
或者是31年之後拿
那個感覺
差異就更小了
當然我不會舉例100年或101年後拿
因為人類壽命是有限的嘛
所以
我是講10年11年之後
這個時間不一致性
也是
人類必定會有的一個心理偏誤
就是
時間不一致性並不是說
我現在很喜歡吃牛肉麵
然後
過了
三年之後
我的胃口變了
我的偏好變了
所以我後來就
比較喜歡吃炒飯
不喜歡吃牛肉麵
現在
他說的是
就算
整件事情完全相同
而且這個人的偏好
也完全沒有任何改變的情況下
你在未來
會做出跟現在完全不一樣的決定
就是完全同樣一個人
然後他的喜好也完全沒有變
個性也完全沒有變
但是在同一個
對同一件事情
他還是做出了
完全不一樣的決定
他現在做的決定在未來是會沒有辦法維持的
好
這個
這個我們快要講到最後
時間不一致性講的就是
不要相信未來的自己
你現在制定的很多東西
是有可能會被未來的你給打破的
所以如果
我們能夠建立一套制度
來控制自己的話
制度不是為了限制現在的你
制度是為了限制未來的你
那他可以避免你在未來
犯你現在沒有辦法預期
或是你現在覺得你不會犯的錯誤
就是
在我們現在沒有遇到這些情況的時候
我們可能就很容易覺得說
我們是可以控制心魔的
那
對呀
我也知道是要這個
長停力短停順
然後
不要有這些outcome bias
不要有這些
控制幻覺
但是
實際上
真的到那個情況的時候是
很有可能是很難
很難去對抗這件事情
所以
我們
需要制度來
就是
控制你自己
那
就是
on-theat
就是上頭
是一種狀態
它指的是
你會完全的破壞規則
然後你會更容易想要下更大的
部位的倉位
然後想要更快的贏回來
那
當然這個就是
原因是因為我們前面有講的嘛
就是如果
如果你有一半的機會輸兩倍
一半的機會變成沒輸的話
平均來說你的快樂程度是比較高的
因為在第三向線
它是一個
這個
concave up的圖形
所以平均來說
這個不停損或者是去硬凹回來
你的快樂程度是會比較高的
所以
on-theat的時候
這個
就是上頭的時候
會很容易想要
這個
加倍下單
然後不停損
那
這個是需要明確的制度規則
而不是控制心魔心態很重要
跟不要貪
那在
這個
就是我跟前一期貨的
這些講座啊
或者是課程裡面都是有
非常嚴格明確的制度
來制定是
怎麼樣控制這些心魔
然後怎麼樣
就是
制定非常明確的
具體可以做的事情
來讓你避免
就是會在上頭的時候
繼續執行這些事情
然後
所以
要避免這些心理偏誤需要的是
一套制度跟規則
然後這套制度規則是有非常明確的
這個要做什麼的
那而不只是說
告訴了你一些概念
然後
希望你這個
自由發揮
然後自己去理解這些概念
那
就是不需要更高的意志力
需要的是一套制度
這樣子
然後
這個
另外一個
是我歸音偏誤就是說
賺錢就因為自己很強
虧錢會因為外在因素
那
這個也是
就是
我會跟我的
這個
打棋惠的
這些學生說
就是
如果你是
執行了
這些策略的話
其實
你會更容易睡得很好
然後會
更容易心理壓力很低
因為
如果你賺錢了
那就是你自己很棒嘛
就是你
遵守了紀律
然後執行了這些數學策略
如果輸錢的話
那就是馬克洋的錯
定這什麼爛策略
害你輸錢
也就是說
贏錢的時候
你覺得自己很棒
輸錢的話
那就是
運氣不好啊
就是川普在搞啊
就是
因為習近平在搞啊
就是你可以
怪東怪西
怪各種不一樣的事情
那
就是
賺錢就是因為自己很棒
輸錢是
這個
外在因素
雖然
Self Attribution Bias
自我歸音偏誤
它是一個
這個行為經濟學偏誤
但是其實我們也可以利用它來
這個讓自己
這個
就是
心理的
過得是更舒服的
好
那反正就是基本上
跟群益期貨這套交易體系
這個課程就是
會有長線的
短線的
然後行為經濟學的這些
這個
就是控制
怎麼樣用一套完整的制度
然後來
控制
避免你
就是
犯一些錯誤
就是把你的
這個
決定權
變成是
這個
依循一套數學策略
依循一套科學化的
這個制度來執行
那這樣的話
這個是
就是
更容易
能夠穩定的
做正確的事情
那如果沒有制度的話
會很容易就是
人性都會讓大家總是做一樣的事情
就很多人都會覺得
每個人其實很不一樣
但
事實上大部分人的
在
在決策思考
面對風險
面對金錢遊戲的時候
大家都是會犯一樣的錯誤
就是
少輸才是
交易中真正的競爭優勢
就是這樣
好
那這個最後兩頁
就是不要靠盤感跟直覺投資
應該要建立一套體系
然後這個體系的所有規則行動
都有具體明確的
規則來規範是怎麼樣進出場的
如果大家有看過我的YouTube影片
或者是
看過我在
爐石或是其他遊戲
我的教學都是
超級明確的
具體的讓你知道
你要做什麼
而不是
說這個是某一個概念
某一個想法
然後
你看完是完全不知道的
無論是
我的期貨的教學
或是我的21點教學
都是這樣子
就是
我最近
也是印了一本
這個快要200頁的
21點的講義
就是專門是用來
訓練更多的21點算牌手
然後裡面就是講了
非常詳細在
各家不同的賭場
應該要做什麼樣
完全不一樣的事情跟策略
然後
非常非常具體跟細節
那
就是反正呢
我的教學風格就是我覺得
我可以把我會的所有事情都交給
就是跟我學習的人
那
是完全
不會有說什麼
我故意
遺漏了一些細節
讓你沒有辦法學到我的全套
這個
我都是
非常具體
非常非常明確的
講
就是這個情況下
那是要用什麼樣的方式來做決策
那當然
這個缺點就是
因為
你做的事情是
非常明確的嘛
所以你輸錢
你就
非常的可以怪我
就是因為
因為大部分
教學者他們會
想要
達到的效果
就是他講了很多
安全廢話
就像是AI
講了很多
大道理
然後全部都是廢話
你
聽完之後
如果你做了
然後
賠錢了
你會覺得說
這個是我沒有體悟到老師的那個生意
他這邊說
這個要控制心魔
那我沒控制好心魔
是不是發生這樣的情況
但是
就是我是一個數學家嘛
在
在這些
金錢的遊戲裡面
最重要的就不是
預測未來
像是玩21點
也不是說
預測下一張牌會出現什麼
而是我們建立一套
正期望值的事情
然後長期的
穩定的
去執行它
所以
就是在期貨裡面
我們也不是說
我預測了
下一個月
這個是會上漲
下一個月這三個股票
上漲這三個股票下跌
不是這樣子的
是
我們
就是制定了一套
正期望值的策略
然後再制定了一套
告訴你
每一次應該要下注
怎麼樣調整你的下注比例
然後怎麼樣控制你的
情緒
讓你可以
有紀律的正確的執行
這一些
數學策略體系的
科學化的情緒管理制度
然後讓你可以正確地
穩定地執行這些體系
好
那這個最後就一樣
再
講一次
就是說
其實
賭場
最怕的
最強的玩家
他不是說
超級有創意
然後在
林場
就使用了
巧妙的簽署
然後
巧妙的跟
核官進行了一個
鬥志
然後就說
這個以後我來的地方
就是上帝禁區
不是像
這麼帥的這種情況
是
我們建立了一套
體系跟制度
然後有紀律的
穩定的執行
那這個才是
賭場認定的
真的很厲害的優勢玩家
好
這個我們
講座的部分就到這邊
謝謝大家
講座的部分結束
然後
就是我現在是有加入群益期貨
那
就是有跟群益期貨
推出一套
這個課程
那當然
我是
我其實是希望
就是
不要收太
不要有太多學生
所以呢
就是呢
我覺得大概有個
20個學生
差不多就可以了
然後這是一個跟群益期貨的
一起的一個
操盤手訓練計劃
那
這個操盤手訓練計劃呢
我認為不適合大部分的人
就是呢
這個在這邊的
95%以上的人呢
我覺得都是不適合你的
就首先呢
他是
至少呢如果你是
資產在50萬以下的小資族的話
或是100萬以下的小資族呢
他是完全不適合你的
因為呢
就是其實很多人都會密我說
就是他想要
用幾十萬然後翻身什麼的
就是
不知道大家有沒有玩過那種
世紀帝國啊
或是各種那種要研發科技的遊戲
如果你是在遊戲的初期的話
你應該是要先去研發一些
織布啊
或者是砍樹這樣的技術
那什麼貿易車隊啊
然後錢滾錢這種技術呢
科技呢
不是說他研發的不好
是他應該要晚一點研發
因為
如果你是
50萬的資金的話
你要每一個月平均多賺2萬塊
其實
其實很難
這樣的話
等於是
你一年
要用50萬賺24萬
所以
你一年要賺50%
那
一年要賺50%的話
你要學習的知識
其實就蠻多
你就是需要讀很多書
你學很多的知識
但是呢
就當然你學了很多知識之後
這個
這個就會是一個
可以達成目標
很大的資金的話
會很不容易一年賺50%
但是越小的資金會越容易達成
那但是
如果你是在
小資的階段的話
實際上你花的時間
也都是要有成本的
那
你研發這個
錢滾錢科技的時間
其實
你
先想辦法讓自己
每個月多賺2萬塊
會明顯簡單非常多
當然
一個月多賺2萬塊
還是需要花一點點的
努力跟時間啦
就是
不是說你
用一樣的時間
躺在沙發上看Netflix
然後你就可以
賺到一個月多2萬塊
還是要多花一點點努力
但是
就算啦
最不計
就是你去
跑Uber
送外送
一個月也都很容易多賺2萬
當然實際上我是
非常不建議年輕人
去
就是
執行那種
純粹賣掉自己的壽命
然後
然後沒有學習價值的事情
但我的意思是說
如果你是
這個
就是
資產100萬以下的小資主的話
我都
因為每一個
密我
就是
說自己才是學生或小資主的人
我都是
百分之百跟他說
你先不要跟我學期
或因為
就是
就是你的那個科技
科技數還沒有點到這個地方
你應該先點的是
想辦法讓自己多賺一點錢
然後可能每個月多賺2萬
如果你一直沒有辦法成功研發這個科技的話
你就永遠
有可能永遠點不到錢滾錢的那個科技
那也沒辦法
因為這個
這個遊戲就是這樣
就是
以數學圖表來說
在
最一開始的時候
線性增加是比指數增加還快的
就是
你每個月線性的多賺2萬塊
跟一年多賺20%
在你數字還很小的時候
一年多賺20%
每年乘以1.2
其實增加比較慢
所以
就是
我說的是
純粹以數學的角度
不考慮
學習進步和
學新遊戲很好玩這件事的話
就是
你一開始先
線性的讓自己資產增加
然後
後面在
遊戲的中期之後
再
用指數的
增加
然後去學習這些
錢滾錢的技術的話
純數學來說是比較好的
那當然
這個
股票投資這個也是
學新遊戲嘛
就是
學新遊戲還是有很多其他額外的附加價值
例如說
學新遊戲很好玩
學新遊戲讓你變聰明
學新遊戲讓你認識更多的人
然後
有很多的研究都是說
你的資產
水平
或是你的收入水平
會跟你
最常相處
或是最常聽他說話的五個人的平均
那
如果你像大師學習的話
你確實
會比較容易
提高你的收入
但是
就是
但是還是有遊戲階段的問題
一開始還沒有到這個遊戲階段
然後再來就是
這段就是講的比較誠實一點
就是
在股票市場裡面
會有一些人贏錢
然後也會有一些人輸錢
那
平均來說
這個
比較笨的人
還是會比較容易輸錢一點
所以你如果覺得自己
應該是
這個
智商是比較低的那一半的話
那其實呢
我通常都是覺得
你一輩子不要進行任何投資
是比較好的
真的
就是
也不要說什麼
什麼
買大盤
然後
定期定額
因為實際上
就是我們剛剛學習到了嘛
如果你買了一個
ETF
然後他虧了
因為其實很有可能
你剛買的時候
他會先虧10%
這個都是
超級正常
因為你是一個
無限時間的
的投資嘛
所以
你如果是先虧了10%
你有可能就會在
漲到變成
原本那個
就是原本數字的時候
就把它賣掉
也就是說
只要他的路徑是先虧的
他就
他能夠達到的結果就是
最後
原地退場
或者是
虧錢
那這樣就反而變成一個
-EV的策略
反正就是
如果你評估你自己應該是
屬於比較
沒有那麼聰明的
全人類裡面比較不聰明的
50%的人的話
其實我是覺得
就是一輩子都不要投資
連什麼長期買進大盤
都不要
因為
人性就會讓你沒有辦法
那麼好的執行這些事情嘛
當然還有一些其他原料
例如說你
急需用錢的時候
你可能會需要賣掉股票
那這個也一樣會
破壞了你原本想要的投資策略
然後
或者是
你想要長期買進大盤
你也不一定能夠
這個做到對的事情
有可能
你會覺得說
那我就是買個高股息的
什麼東西
那可能也是非常不好嘛
可能買到
台灣價值高股息什麼
那也有可能
就是
大盤都已經漲到天上去了
然後他都還沒有回到發行價
這樣也不是很好
就是
就是投資這個遊戲
他
他就是一個
有可能贏也可能輸的遊戲
那你可以
想辦法學習更多的知識
讓你
可以長期穩定的
獲得一個正期望值的效果
但是
但是他
這整個遊戲過程中
你需要連續做對很多很多很多的事情
才可以得到一個比較好的效果
那
其中有
幾個環節
是犯了一個錯誤
有可能
那一個錯誤就會
把你整個遊戲體系
的結果
變成是一個不好的結果
好
反正呢
至少
大多數人是
開心的
穩定的
在
贏錢
當然這個是不可能
不可能
所有人都是贏錢的嘛
就是
實際上
還是會有一些人他們是會
就是會發生各式各樣不同的錯誤
有一些錯誤可能都不是
一開始容易
想到的
可能就例如說
一個人他覺得
這是一個很棒的交易機會
可是他現在正在搭高鐵
然後他就決定用他的
在搭高鐵的手機下單
然後他就進入了一個隧道裡面
然後他網路就斷訊了
然後在斷訊出來之後
他發現他賠了100萬
就是
就有很多的錯誤有可能是
是很荒謬
而且你原本沒有辦法預期的
當然
當然這個
這個其實也都是
都是我裡面
我盡量啦
會收入各式各樣
有可能會犯的錯誤
然後盡量避免大家
大家不要
不要犯
就是
說
一定要在
你交易限定的那個電腦
然後網路非常好的環境下單
但是
其實這個也真的
不一定那麼容易有做到
我之前
FB也有貼過一個
一個
一篇
就是
那次我是從
應該是
拉斯維加斯回來的飛機
然後那是一個
超級正期望值
一個很好的交易機會
然後
我就
就在飛機上下單
那飛機上的那個
就算你是買付費的網路
那個WiFi也真的是很爛
然後
我就在飛機上下單
就是
搭一個飛機的過程
就輸了200多萬
那時候有貼對賬單
就是
其實
這個跟
那個在高鐵上面
過山洞下單
其實根本就差不多
而且
是我的學生已經發生過在
高鐵過山洞下單
然後我還在飛機上下單
就是
這個
這整個
世界裡面
它實際上可以發生的錯誤
是
是很多的
那就算是我
學習了很多東西
我還是有可能
這個犯了一個
很奇怪的錯誤
然後就
突然就虧了200萬之類
就是
然後另外就是
在
整個
投資的過程當中
一定會是
是有賺有賠有賠
然後也不一定是
會很
錯綜的相間
你是很有可能
執行一個
非常好的
正期望值策略
例如說21點
有可能你
上桌的前10把牌
都是輸錢的
然後而且還沒有被作弊
這個都是
當然這個只有
一千分之一的機會
但是就是
都還是有可能會發生
例如說
至少連輸五把牌
那也是很接近
如果都是二分之一
也是三十分之一左右
就是
如果你要
能夠
穩定的
執行這些東西的話
你需要
的是
是要連續做對很多事情
然後而且
就是
你要
基本上還是要
不能是
太笨的人
這樣子
好
那當然啦
實際上
這些
交易的東西
他
最
最難的是
制定這一套策略
然後
執行這些策略是相對
非常簡單
非常非常的多
那所以
不論是
這個
無論是
是
21點
股票期貨
製定策略的這部分
我都已經
幫各位完成了
如果真的跟我學習的
如果跟我學習的人的話
的話就只需要學習
怎麼樣子
穩定的執行他
那這個難度當然比自訂策略是
簡單非常的多
但是呢
他也
不是保證一個會成功的事情
那所以
就是雖然呢
今天來了
這個非常多人
但是呢
我覺得
就是也不需要
真的收很多學生
這個大概就是
最多
20個
我覺得就差不多
做不到20個
我覺得也
也非常的不錯
這樣子
好
看起來這個
長官非常的不同意
好
那
各位來
我稍微就是說明一下
這個
謝謝
剛剛長長的
給你一個人講
那
大家可以想一下
如果那個
那
看一下大家現在有什麼
想要問的問題
可以舉手
那我們來
請馬開來回覆一下
好
我們這場地好像是非常不錯
他好像是可以按那個
麥克風
我們來試驗一下
我
前幾天有來試驗一下
好像每個人的麥克風
都可以直接講話
哇
你看我們花錢租這場地
還是非常值得的
就是
因為我是
馬開來的醫師你好
就是我
我其實也是一位異學生
然後
就是我就是你口中說的小刺主
只是我
在想的一個問題是
就是因為
可能像你也知道
醫學系的養成過程是
後期其實是有點忙的
然後
他進到住院醫師以後
是
我覺得看盤的機率
或者是那些機會
會明天超很多
所以
雖然我現在大二
然後
我想
就是
我學
股票的
操作過程是想要透過
在這六年的時間
就先翻出
可能有一段的本金
然後後面在
然後
後面在
呃
就是因為我覺得到後期
我是沒有那個時間
就是我前面達成
100萬以後
我可能就沒有時間變成
專業的操作
所以
我想要在
有可能
機會達到
100萬錢
去達
就是因為
但我這個想法跟你
剛剛建議的是
不太相處的
所以
呃
我比較好奇
你在
呃這個過程
是怎麼去
構思
就是你到底是在哪一個階段
去學習
這一些操盤的
技巧
然後
呃是怎麼在當
呃可能
原本在當醫生的時間
去學習到
這一些難題的
好好好
他問了一個
很棒的問題
呃我現在講的就是
特定他的情況
因為醫學生的
家教
的那個
時薪其實是可以很不錯
我是很容易超過1000的
然後
我自己
以前因為
高中的時候
拿過世界冠軍嘛
然後
這個世界上
是有很多
真的很有錢的人
當然
台灣也是有很多
真的很有錢的人
然後
所以他們是
會想要說
小朋友要來
學打籃球啊
就請林舒豪來教他一下
這個
林舒豪也在台灣嘛
說不定有空啊
目前請林舒豪
教小朋友
運球啊
拍一拍球啊
這個
所以
就是有些人會想要
請我拿過世界冠軍來教他的小朋友
所以
當時
我雖然
才大學
但是
我就是開一個小時3000
那當然
可能
這個就是我的目標客群
就不是
不是
普通的人嘛
就是
我那時候
開一個小時3000
然後是
是可以
就是排得滿滿的
而且
有很多的家長
是他們最後要付錢的時候
然後他們才又在問我
就是他可能小孩已經上了30個小時的課了
然後
最後要付錢的時候
他才又在問老師說
老師你那時候說一個小時多少
我忘記了
然後我說3000
就是便宜到他沒有印象你知道嗎
就是當然對我自己來說啦
我自己都不想請自己
一個小時3000
交高中數學
一對一
當然一對一本來就比較貴
但是就是
就是
你總是還是可以找到你想要的客群
那
然後
另外一個是很有趣的是
我有時候
那時候有交一個大老闆的小孩
然後
我說我
從
這個地方過去
他們那邊上課
然後他說
你這樣子來回
應該要花一個小時吧
那你交兩個小時的課
那我可不可以付你三個小時的錢
我這個要求第一次聽到過
就是大老闆他們是這個
收服人心嘛
一個小時3000
他兩個小時付你三個小時的錢
這個
他覺得
就多付3000
零錢
隨便付一付也沒多少錢
可能
你會更用心啊
你會覺得
這個
搞不好他有想這個企業形象的問題嗎
就是
我真的講過很多次這個故事
如果私下的話
我就會講是哪一個老闆
他這個3000塊宣傳效果也是
也是蠻大的
好
那這個稍微講了一些
無關的有趣的事情
就是說呢
就是如果是醫學生的話
我覺得啦
前面線性的先
先
就是
當家教一個
就算一個小時
只開1000塊
當然一個小時1000塊
這個是非常不錯的事情
這個絕對是非常多錢
但我是說
醫學系的
學生是很容易達到的
那當然你一開始可以先接一些
800塊的
然後
也同時接1000塊的
你接到1000塊之後
可以稍微退掉一些800塊
就是
如果你
時薪1000塊
其實要賺到100萬
應該是
真的是非常簡單的一件事
然後
在你一開始
線性增加你的資產之後
你後面要錢滾錢就會簡單很多
那
我自己的投資策略
大部分是幾乎不太需要花時間看盤的
就是
我的長線交易都是
長線交易本來就不用看盤嘛
就看一些財報
看一些資料就可以
短線交易大部分是事件交易嘛
事件交易的話就是
事件就是
大部分的事件它都是
特定在什麼時間
然後會宣佈
什麼樣的經濟數據
或者是會發生什麼事情
這個都是
提前就可以預知的
例如說
總統就職
或者是說
每個月
會公佈很多很多的經濟數據
這個
PMI
然後
PPI
PCE
就是很多很多的經濟數據
這些
會公佈的時間點都是固定的
而且
在美國的經濟數據公佈都是台灣的晚上
所以
每個月需要花的看盤時間
和下單次數
在我的短線交易裡面都是非常非常少的
所以
就是
實際上
我大部分時候
都是
非常悠閒的
就是
我大部分時候都是
真的
就是很輕鬆啊
所以我每年都才會學很多個新遊戲啊
所以我去年
才可以有超過半年都在國外旅遊
然後
然後我也學了新的那個Shadowverse
就是那個暗影十張卡牌遊戲
然後也打到四伏器第一
然後
在我過去
四年
我打那個炉石戰記的時間
就是我已經退休不當那個職業選手
好像
好像過去
幾年
我還那個戰場還打了六千多個小時吧
反正就是
實際上我是超級悠閒的
對
就是雖然
雖然我是做那個股票期貨交易
但是
我是完全不需要就是一直盯盤一直看的
因為
因為其實
其實就是一直看也沒什麼用嘛
如果你
買了一些台積電
然後你一直看那個台積電
台積電也不會漲比較快啊
加油
漲
其實也沒什麼用嘛
其實也不用看
我自己是覺得
盡量都不用看
沒有關係
當然我完全可以理解
大部分人其實買了之後
每天都會很想看
但是我自己是不一定會看
好
那反正呢
這個問題分成兩段
第一段是說
如果你是醫學生的話
你有一個非常簡單的
賺錢入境
就是
去那樣家教一個小時賺一錢
然後呢
你有錢之後呢
其實事實上好的投資策略
是不需要花很多時間看盤的
就是
我自己的
那個
期貨學生
應該超過一半都是工程師
然後工程師都
上班時間是很長的
然後當然也有一些是醫生
但是
確實大部分是工程師
然後工程師
我自己也覺得
個性上
確實是會比較適合
首先是
工程師本來比較聰明嘛
然後他們
大部分我們這些理工宰男
情緒也是比較平穩的
就是比較不容易
很安很上頭
甚至
有過幾個
這個工程師他們是
是
上一次演講
有一個人問我說
欸
為什麼會有
會有人他
不停損
然後
他輸錢了之後
還要加碼
去凹單
那這樣他難道他是想要輸更多錢嗎
就是
就是他的情緒平穩到他沒有辦法同理
大部分人是非常的不理性的
那
好這個
有點講太遠了
我只是說
就是
工作時間很長很忙的工程師
其實還是
非常容易的
穩定的執行
我各式各樣的策略的
就是
並不會因為你上班時間很長
所以你就沒有辦法
就是
進行
事件交易
或者是長線的
看股票
因為
因為股票大部分時候其實是不需要看的
所以
就是
然後
像我就是很悠閒嘛
因為
就是不需要
不需要上班
然後可以一直出去玩
好
那
大概是這樣
好
我們借了那個場地
有那個麥克風真的很不錯
大家
可以踴躍的
我們輪流好
楊大師你好
嗨
我真正覺得
你是我的偶像指引
就是
傳奇的人生有
當過醫師
然後職業電信等等等等
然後
我想要請教一下
就是在
楊大師
你現在這樣子
那
財富對你來講
是一個怎麼樣的一個意義
或者是說你
下一步會想做什麼
因為
您也提到說
像去年你就學了一個
卡牌遊戲跟21年
那
對您來講
現在財富現在已經是自由了嘛
那
也許會不會有其他的追求
就是
可以給我們這些
一些
我們還在財富邊緣掙
這些人的一些歧視
哇
這個是一個哲學問題啊
這個非常
非常有哲思
好
就是
其實我也不是
什麼操報有錢
然後可以
買遊艇
私人飛機
就是我自己的
物質欲望
我自己覺得是
是很低的啊
就是
就是我
從小都被教要非常節省
就我從
小學的時候
那時候
爸爸媽媽問我要什麼生日禮物
然後我就說那
那時候哈利波特每一年會出一本
我就說那不然你每年生日禮物就送我
買一本哈利波特給我就好了
居然
小朋友每一年想要的唯一的禮物是一本書
這是真的是
然後就是
就我的物質欲望其實是很低很低啦
所以
我通常也不是說我是財富自由
我通常是覺得我是人身自由
就是
也不是說我想要買個遊艇
然後我就直接把遊艇買下來
然後
就是不是這樣
就是
至少我可以完全的支配我的人生
要做我自己想要做的事情都可以
那
我是很喜歡學新東西嘛
所以
我去年就做了我自己覺得很有趣的事情
其中一個就是
就是跟TrackGVT學算牌
然後去做這些有趣的事
那
如果是講
更general的理論體系的話呢
快樂有分三個要素
然後
第一個是satisfaction
就是享受
享受你的生活
然後
不對
滿足是另外一個
第一個是享受你的生活
就是
你整個生活裡面
有多
高比例的時間是在做你不想要做的事
那如果你
你常常需要去上班
但其實你很不喜歡上班的話
那你的享受這個項目的
評分就是
會比較低嘛
然後第二個是滿足
就是說
你認為你自己
可以
該擁有的全部東西
跟你實際上擁有的東西的差異有多大
那
滿足這件事情呢
不一定是你有超多錢就可以很滿足了
例如說
郭台銘他認為
自己應該可以當台灣的總統
你看川普當總統
我怎麼當不了
我想要選
他都不給我選
所以
像郭台銘他的
滿足這一段可能就是
其實
快樂程度是很低的
因為他覺得自己
可以擁有的是當總統
結果
發現自己
居然是因為太窮
所以沒有辦法
連選都沒有辦法選
他應該
還是會有一些
這一段的不快樂
然後第三個就是
人生的意義
就是每個人人生的意義
可能都很不一樣
不一定要有很多錢
然後
就是
例如說
陳述局
在台灣很有名
他捐了很多錢出去
那
他也不是最後有很多錢
他可能
人生的意義是
他最喜歡的是
幫助別人
然後獲得大家的感謝
這個不是貶低喔
就是
有些人很喜歡幫助別人
然後獲得別人的感謝
就是
這個是
一個類型的人
就是會
會這樣
然後這也是非常好的
道德非常高尚
就並不會因為你喜歡被別人感謝
所以你道德就降低
沒有這樣子
那
就是
我們
要達成自己人生的意義
其實不需要
賺很多錢
才可以達成
你也可以
不是很有錢
但是你人生的意義
可能是
教育好你的小孩
然後讓你的小孩
快樂樂樂的長大
成為一個
成功的人
可能這個是你人生的意義
那
要達成這個意義
就是
也不用到真的賺超爆多錢嘛
其實在台灣
花一兩千萬
一生就可以
把一個小孩養大
反正就是說
我這樣講的是
心理學理論
快樂的三個要素就是
享受自己的生活
然後
滿足自己擁有的東西
跟找到人生的意義
所以
我覺得大部分人
就是
想辦法讓人生
都是想辦法讓自己獲得
更多的快樂
所以
應該想辦法
增加的就是
你怎麼更享受自己的生活
然後更滿意
自己現在擁有的東西
然後
找到自己人生的意義
而且
盡量的往自己人生意義去追尋
然後
你會發現
這三個裡面
沒有任何一項是賺錢
你不只是
當然賺錢會讓你
更容易的
享受生活
然後
想要做什麼
就做什麼嘛
它可能
可以
稍微降低
這個遊戲難度
但是
就是人生最後破關
不是說
什麼你賺到了多少錢
然後你人生就
破關
人最後就都死掉了嘛
應該大家有玩過很多遊戲
也沒有任何一個遊戲
它的
通關條件是
什麼你累積到了300萬的
遊戲金幣
然後你就通關了
顯然不是嘛
一定是
那個人生目標
最後的那個任務
你把那個任務解完
才是真的人生破關
這樣
就是呢
我自己大概是
每三個月左右就會
更新一次我的策略組合
所以
雖然
它是一套
就是
聽起來是一個體系
但是實際上
我是會一直加入新的策略
然後刪掉一些舊的策略
那個助理說
說我們時間好像差不多了
好那反正呢
就是
你只要
密我的那個FB
那我的FB就會自動
有機器人給你我的LINE
然後呢
就是大家要找到我
都是非常簡單的
你們也可以在我的FB下面留言
這樣的話
大家也可以看到你問什麼
如果你比較
害羞的話
你也可以私訊我
好
好讓助理說那個
時間要結束了
好就先這樣吧
大家拜拜
好
祝福大家的高中的講述